um hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's welcome actually to five nights
at freddy's 2 I was not ready for that
holy hell I got early access to the demo
of the extended version of the demo with
Scott Cawthon I still don't know how to
pronounce his name said there are three
nights available to play and I am so
excited to get into it I really want to
play oh boy that looks kind of creepy
pop wanted grand reopening vintage a new
life hello
I want to reassure you fazbear
entertainment is committed to family fun
and above all faith they've spent a
small fortune on this new animatronics
facial recognition advanced mobility
they even let them walk around during
the day that means but most importantly
they're all tied into some kind of
criminal database so they can detect a
predator a mile away
hey we should be paying them to guard
you now that being said no new system is
about it tink you're only the second
guard to work at that location the first
guy finished his week but complained
about conditions we switched him over
the day shift so Hey look right now
mainly it's where's concerned that
certain character seems to move around
at night even attempted to get into his
office now what do we know that should
be impossible that restaurant should be
the safest place on earth so while our
engineers don't really have an
explanation whether he's working theory
is that the robots were never given a
proper night clothes so like it's quiet
they think they're in the wrong room so
then they go try to find where the
people are in this case that's your
office okay so our temporary solution is
that there's a music box over by the
prize counter and it's rigged to be
wound up remotely so every once in a
while watch over the prior counter video
feed line it up for a second
you may have noticed there are no doors
for you to close but hey you have a life
and even though your flashlight why'd
you say golden dude what do you sound
like that guy that probably died in the
last one who the hell are you supposed
to be there's so many things I need to
keep track of
oh god this is much worse where are they
oh I'm all right Bonnie's out and the
new Bonnie's out oh god where's blondie
wheres blondie wheres blondie wheres
blondie where's Bonnie
oh hi Bonnie I love your new suit you're
looking good today
okay this should just be the first night
so it should be relatively easy compared
to other things how in the world am i
doing that why did he have to say golden
where are there so many bad things about
this oh god I have no idea what all this
is about
there's the new Freddy
like Bonnie's still there the first
night should be nothing no problem just
I don't even know what this is supposed
to do is it keeping is it keeping
someone to sleep oh that new foxy I'm
glad it's gone
oh god I'm chewing through power like
nobody's business I don't even know if
you guys can see where my power meter is
it's behind my head at the moment unless
this is like stuck in I can tell I'll
figure something out so that you guys
can see the power I don't know how I'm
gonna do it I'm a little bit of a panic
right now nothing seems to be after me
at the moment
Oh God hi how you doing bonbon
you doing good you look good where's
everybody else I got I don't even
remember no no no no no no oh
chicas out she goes oh I don't know I'm
guessing no no oh god what why
holy balls
okay okay this is too many things I need
to worry about right now god the music
box I don't know I don't know how
important this is what I'm gonna do it
as if it's the most important thing okay
oh my god calm down jack I'm not gonna
die
where's chica I seldom found chica
Oh
oh hi hi Freddie
is it really game over already all right
all right I can find shaker aah
Oh what happened I'm so worried about
freaking Bonnie over there who's gonna
die okay oh god damn it's so weird being
back into this and I think I know five
nights at Freddy's and that's very
obvious that I do not okay he's got to
keep this thing wound up tight I gotta
get through night one the least I can do
is survive night one I didn't even see
chica coming oh and that's not a joke
for the internet to enjoy okay
so bonnie is still there they're all
still there they're all very happy so
apparently the battery now only drains
the flashlight so there's no way to run
out of power and just have Freddy jump
you in the middle of the night
and as you can see I'm wearing my lucky
flannel for this because I thought I'd
need it didn't seem to help me what is
that sound
did you taste like that
oh god I have their worst heebie-jeebies
and those adorable little creatures
aren't helping me much either way
everything's fine for now I think it's
gonna be fine just happen to make sure
that they don't leave should be okay
till they leave now I'm just wondering
where the hell foxy is because I know
that foxy is out there somewhere he's
not dead
this is gonna be a fun adventure how am
I gonna do five nights of this for even
less money than I did before or was it
last money I don't even remember how
much money I got before oh maybe it's
more money I don't know maybe it's more
or less money all right so this approach
this calmly and collectively so I can
see like the vent entrance on these
locations these are just different party
rooms that are available around this is
where all the old animatronics are but
I'm guessing they're not down and out
forever they're all still there we're
all still good we're still doing fine
that lovely desktop fan is still there
to help me out it all is gonna be good
why is golden Freddy over there on the
right
why are all the Freddy characters
eyeless and soulless okay Bonnie oh no
Bonnie's still there good good good good
okay so my five nights at Freddy's
instincts need to come back on me so
that I can actually not die a horrible
horrible death someone moving Oh
someone's moving okay where are ya
rawr yes you sassy sue ha yeah I'm the
bow you're playing the banjo there or
whatever it is I don't know electric
guitar or something I don't know how the
hell I was supposed to stop chica I am
spazzing out to some extreme degree
right now oh all right then
Karl old buddy howdy bunny friend got
that wind-up music box it degrades a lot
quicker if you're not looking at it I
swear
so that's like I don't know what that's
supposed to see see look at that look at
that are you looking at that where'd he
go
okay still there I don't even know how
those are supposed to help me maybe like
chica was poking her head out of one of
those vents and I why no no no you don't
go in that vent
don't and don't play that music I don't
know what that is it's not my music box
Oh God I just know I'm gonna look one of
these times and all those little
antibiotics you gotta be looking right
at Gabby oh god oh god oh god like it oh
god why don't you wait right there right
there but he's not here yet Oh God take
us out Oh what do I do for cheetah
what'll we do for chica what do I do if
I take out I don't know how to do for
chica Oh what do I do for chica
oh I gotta check oh my goodness I don't
even know where chick is oh god I gotta
check both diner called ina
oh god I'm [ __ ]
how's the music box sick he's gonna kill
a oh god I'm getting lightheaded oh god
oh god oh god oh god I couldn't put my
flashlight down the hallway well that's
bad
well that's real bad that plussing light
is bad Oh God Oh God I need to do
something
have you feeling good oh [ __ ]
well then all right can't do nothing now
she gives if she wants to serve me a
cupcake I think it was I know the Flies
what does that music mean when it stops
husbad was bad screw you I'm stayin here
Oh God she didn't go away I even get a
good look at it had a face how am I
gonna beat the first night this is
impossible
Oh God okay all right okay we got this
okay I don't know what to do in the face
of chica oh god damn don't let that
music box can unwound I'm guessing that
when she's there and she's stood there
for a long time it doesn't immediately
mean that I'm dead it's just if I I
don't know I don't know I couldn't get
to it I'm still afraid she was gonna
murder my face new chicas not fun new
chica is unfun you chica is the least
fun okay all right so I think I've
gotten a better idea of what I'm
supposed to do here other than panic so
music box
absolutely 100% priority
my heart is going a million billion
miles an hour by the way my heart is
literally about to explode out of my
chest I knew something bad was gonna
happen I knew it didn't matter if I had
that on that was Oh God
that thing that thing whatever it was
was not an animatronic I don't know why
it exists what is that to torture the
babies
oh wait a minute if you see oh it's on
the walls there that's the thing I don't
know why supposed to be but it's worse
than anything oh excuse me
Barney that's very rude I just ate
before I did this by a bad idea like
swimming right after you eat you know
you're gonna die
drowned horribly okay I was getting home
man I was panicking so hard I was
getting a little light-headed the last
round I'm not joking oh whoa that was
not good I was hyperventilating
I need a paper bag to breathe in and out
for this game god damn it's the first
night in a friggin demo it's not
supposed to be this bad okay let me look
around that's still very creepy I don't
know what's going on there I'm trying to
look around to make sure that everything
is hunky-dory on the walls that balloon
guy probably is another guy I need to
worry about okay those are the dudes who
face fun I know that that was probably
like a golden Freddy Easter eggs
somewhere in here I just got to get
through the first night to be able to do
it come on I'm gonna king of five nights
at Freddy's I can do this well it's the
king of the first game not the king of
this game for damn sure
I'm Ron battery way too low but I think
I can actually use more than I think I
can because games not gonna end I just
want to be able to look look with my
flight's and obviously I can't just stay
hidden under the mask because otherwise
they're gonna Myrtle eyes my face
Bonnie's being nice Bonnie hasn't left
yet Bonnie's still there music box it's
nice and wound I don't know who decides
to unwind that sumbitch but they are not
a nice person they're very much not nice
Bonnie is still there oddly enough
everything's okay unless that means that
the other guys are coming out to see me
oh there's chica over on the left Oh
chicas had better days I like how they
made chica more definitely a chicken and
not a duck it was my mistake in the
earlier episodes that I recorded five
nights at Freddy's way back in the
beginning way back when I didn't know
any better way back when I thought that
everything was happy and fun and that it
was sunshine and rainbows blasting out
my ass is this gonna be a friendly
adventure filled with happy memories now
I know better
everything's a living nightmare always
and forever eternally forever burning in
my mind
hi Bonnie you got a quick I was just
looking at you somewhere else so what
are you doing over there Bonnie why do I
need to look at you is it important to
be able to look at them frequently
that's something that I don't know if
it's true I have no idea to be honest I
have no God hi okay so he seems to make
a bit of a pattern going in between
those spots I want to think that the
developer this game Scott decided that
it would be a better idea to actually
need to watch the people and see where
they are because doing that is probably
gonna add my survival in some way don't
know in what way but in some okay okay
that's bad that's bad
that's okay so that means to see he's
close so on the audio cues are there to
make sure that I know what's going on
without me hearing it
oh is that chica I think I think I think
sugar might be up yep chicas out okay
that's bad that's bad it's very bad very
bad very bad very bad
where's chica I gotta find chica I've no
God they oh there's chica oh hi chica
hi Oh God okay carne he's in the vents
he's in the vents he's in the vents he's
in the men's that's okay he's just gonna
skate on by I mean every goddamn
opportunity to wind up this goddamn
music box okay I don't know where chica
went kind of forget where chica was
bathroom yeah she likes the bathrooms
she's the bathroom kind of bird he's
still in there Freddy's out oh boy this
is fun it's a fun adventure oh god what
was that what was I even looking at Oh
God
he's still there Freddie's not there
she's not there what's he a [ __ ] oh god
how am I supposed to know what he's gone
oh because that does not help me at all
oh my me just an animatronic damn it oh
god damn it
okay look I've run out again hey bye
Barney
oh god that's bad luck
I don't know what this means it uh no no
God again with this thing it was the
first night who's incredibly stressful
oh I get it
okay so anyway that was just the first
damn night I am out of here I'm out here
no no screw you I'm out I know I'm out
I'm out we're gonna save this for later
I'm done not listen to the call [ __ ]
just exited the game oh that was bad
didn't mean to do that
please don't corrupt my video okay
didn't crop so thank you all so much for
watching I am done with the first night
of the demo of five nights at Freddy's 2
god damn oh my heart is racing a billion
miles an hour is gonna be a fantastic
game I don't know when the full game
comes out I know that the public demo is
not available just yet but you will see
more five nights at Freddy's 2 from me
over the next few days as I try to beat
the first three nights but it took that
long for the first night then again I
had to relearn some stuff so it should
be a lot of fun oh God so anyway click
the annotations over there for all the
runs to tell the five nights at Freddy's
that I've done check out that five
nights at Freddy's animations that we're
done it's all a lot of fun so thank you
all so much for watching now
always I will see you